- Nuh uh, uh, uh, uh.
Girl, where are your pants?
- [Girl] It's a dress.
- Nuh uh, nope.
Not today. Absolutely not.
You are half naked.
- Are you?
- [Mom] Go, am I serious?
Yes.
(vaudeville music)
Go back in there
and change.
- [Daughter] Mom!
- Sorry, that's not gonna work.
- [Daughter] God, I'm gonna be late.
- No, I don't care if
you're gonna be late.
Go back in that room and change.
Not today, honey.
- [Daughter] God.
- I don't know what you think this is.
Well who do you think you're talkin' to?
Do I look like one of your friends?
Do you think I'm just made of money?
Do you hear me talkin' to you?
- I didn't think you
were actually talk to m--
- Oh, you're,
now you're gettin' smart with me.
Oh, you are trying me today,
wearing those stockin' pants.
Got your butt all hangin' out.
I don't think so.
- Are you serious?
- [Mom] Yes, I'm serious.
- Like, I just--
- [Mom] Go, go back in
that room and go change.
Not today, honey.
Nuh uh, not today.
(rap music)
- Hold up, I like that song.
- [Mom] Well,
you can start choosin' songs
once you start payin' for some gas,
okay?
Now get your foot off of my dashboard.
- Oh my God.
- I left your mail on the table.
- Okay.
(folky music)
Let's see.
Mom, really?
- Too busy to answer my calls, huh?
- No, Mom.
- So who were you talkin' to?
It better not be no boy.
Daysha.
Dasha.
- Yeah, yeah Mom?
- Can you get the chicken
out the freezer for me?
That's what we're gonna
have for dinner tonight.
- But you're right here.
- Are you gettin' smart with me?
- No.
- Ain't nobody payin' for no cell phone
so you can talk to no boys.
You can start missin' my calls
when you start payin' some bills.
- So I really want you
to meet my friend Taylor.
- [Mom] Okay.
- Don't "Taylor Rebecca Smith" me, Mom.
Just shut up.
Just shut the (beep) up.
- Is that your friend?
- No.
God, I would never be friends
with someone who talks
to their Mom like that.
- [Mom] Okay...
- Don't let her see you,
but let, I don't know her.
- Are you, no, no, no.
You must think I'm stupid.
Does your sister think I'm crazy?
I know you were at that boy's house.
(laughs)
I know you were at that,
are you laughin' about somethin'?
'Cause I got somethin' for you too,
you just hold on for a minute.
Where are you?
It's gonna be you on there one day.
- Thanks, Mom.
- Of course, baby, I love you.
- I love you too.
- Kay.
(vaudeville music)